in colorado this morning relentless
wildfires are putting thousands of
people in danger more than 600 homes
have burned along with a shopping center
and a hotel you can see how intense the
blaze is tens of thousands have been
evacuated and at least seven people are
hurt conor mchugh of our denver station
kcnc is in louisville colorado northwest
of denver connor those pictures are
incredible
good morning boulder county sheriff says
he would not be surprised if there were
more injuries or even deaths due to the
intensity of this fire that burned and
is still burning just past this
roadblock also how densely populated
this area of boulder county is now take
a look at this police video showing how
within hours a blaze near superior
crossed sixteen hundred acres destroying
hundreds of homes flames were consuming
the length of a football field in just
seconds video taken of people evacuating
a costco showed them stepping into an
apocalyptic scene
mile per hour wind was whipping ash
around shoppers in the parking lot and
inside this chuck e cheese parents and
children rushed for the exits to
evacuate because of nearby flames only
to be stopped by intense winds so strong
it made opening the door difficult but
as you can see they did get out and
flames were visible at a vista adventist
hospital in louisville all patients and
staff had to evacuate and the hospital
was shut down now officials say the
forecast has called for diminishing
winds overnight and into this morning if
that happens that would allow them to
get ahead of the flames and even deploy
some resources that could drop water
from above
connor i hope we can get things under
control soon thank you for that